[Music]
there's Thurston Howell I mean Clayton
Thorson getting selected by the
Philadelphia Eagles we'll do the
play-by-play for those of you listening
on radio his buddy
his buddy his buddies like almost went
saikhan in the second time Oh see ya oh
man
all the cameras on I like that I like
the festivity though they got the little
flags hanging on being a gentleman Wow
his buddy
but I don't know who that guy is we'll
probably never know his name but we'll
never forget the moment where Clayton
Thorsen's buddy was left hanging
twice all right that that probably
should qualify for one of our draft
superlatives best leaving a guy hanging
award I don't know I didn't have enough
time to think of anything better than
that Chris what do you have for us well
I'm gonna go something with one of my
favorite guys when it comes draft time
you know just ER Johnny value pick okay
that's my superlative johnny value okay
is that's Chris Ballard in the Annapolis
Colts again Chris Ballard showing like
like him and maybe a few other teams in
football showing that he's playing chess
when everybody's playing checkers with
the NFL Draft
I mean trades out of the first round
accumulates three second-round picks
okay and then gets three really good
football players in the second round to
improve his team you know rockiest sin
corner at a temple you know was
borderline first-round Talent obviously
goes into 30 pick 34 Ben bonaga
who was one of the great better athletes
in all the draft one of the more
explosive athletes kind of a defensive
end slash outside linebacker from TCU
and then to get Paris Campbell also in
the second round
who for my money was the second best
wide receiver in the draft to pull that
off and again just to have the foresight
to know the players that he liked that
could fill the certain spots on the
roster that needed to be filled I just
can't give enough credit to Chris
Ballard and some of the magic he's
pulled off the last
two years in the draft and keep this in
mind two we discussed this yesterday at
PFT Chad Kelly the former mr. irrelevant
who was number two on the depth chart in
Denver before getting cut by the Broncos
last year had an ugly incident right at
a Halloween party that Von Miller hosted
got thrown out there went to somebody's
house that he doesn't know and got run
out of the house and ultimately pleaded
guilty to second-degree misdemeanor
criminal trespass the Colts are thinking
about reuniting him with Frank Reich
wherever it's the Jim Kelly nephew Frank
Reich and Jim Kelly together in Buffalo
and with Jacobi Brissette due to become
a free agent after this year they cake
it's it's another Johnny value where
this guy's out there he's available to
anyone and it could be Chad Kelly
landing with the Colts they're gonna
make a decision on whether or not to add
him later this week I'm told all right
the loaves and fishes award is my first
superlative and it goes to the Seattle
Seahawks who entered the draft with four
picks they emerged from the draft with
11 picks we knew they were gonna try to
turn four into more they turned four
into 11 it was so bad last week they
were talking about him how important
undrafted free agency was going to be
because that's the only way they were
gonna get their players they ended up
with 11 draft picks they entered with
four they ended with 11 and only one of
the picks was their original pick the
other 10 belong to someone else and the
first 10 players they drafted all came
from power five schools could contribute
right away as rookies that's an
observation made yesterday by Michael
David Smith on Twitter yeah I stole it
from him but the fact that I mention it
makes it less egregious bottom line is
the Seahawks took four picks and turned
them into 11 John Schneider Pete Carroll
working the board to perfection and to
get DK Metcalfe where they did what's at
the bottom around to driving up to snag
him another example of the Seahawks as
you said with Chris Ballard they're
playing Czech chess while everyone else
was playing check yeah exactly and
they're one of the teams that comes to
my mind as soon as I said that comment
about Chris Ballard I mean yeah I mean
it just Schneider is a magician when it
comes to Draft and you know figuring out
who he wants to fill this team again we
got more you know just notice or
information again that
I'm moving on to a new era in Seattle
you know Frank Clark at the door doesn't
matter they're gonna build with young
talent
LJ Collier at the end of the first round
great pick marquise Blair the saintly
from Utah I mean Mike if you watched his
highlights you'd go damn I think that's
kam chancellor jr. so they got that type
of guy and then you mentioned a DK
Metcalf at the end of the second round
I mean arguably the most explosive
athlete in the draft that is a
phenomenal first three picks by the
Seattle Seahawks got to give him a lot
of credit and yeah they're just they're
great at building a team I really got to
give them a lot of credit John Schneider
is amazing all right you know what I
mean I know I know
let me just say one thing about DK
Metcalf I know all the concerns like he
only runs the nine route it's like all
he does is catch touchdowns right here
at a 4-3-3 I mean this guy potentially
I'm not gonna compare him to Randy Moss
yet yeah but if he if he can run down
the field and catch the ball in traffic
and Russell Wilson who's making 35
million a year now he's willing to throw
it to him when it looks like he's
covered and he can come down with it on
a regular basis this could be one of the
steals of all time Oh without a dad this
is the classic case of everybody
overanalyzing too much in the NFL I will
be shocked if it doesn't work you know
they're gonna go they're all going oh he
doesn't run an extensive route treat oh
well I don't know if this guy can do it
I mean he's only one of the freakiest
athletes in the draft I'm not sure he
can make a right turn instead of going
straight whoa we might have to drop him
down in the draft yes there's too much
physical ability there you know I think
other thing you know he rubbed I think
some people wrong and meetings DK
Metcalf then the offense wasn't good at
all mess but like we talked about a
little bit at the start of the show you
know too many times the players are
evaluated for team struggles instead of
just evaluate the player it's not DK
Metcalfe's fault that the offensive
coordinator only had three routes in the
game plan you know that's just all there
was to it I don't know it's not he can't
call the plays so I I don't understand
that always okay my next superlative you
mean it was Avengers weekend so I got to
give up you know some love
it was the Avengers weekend end game I
gotta give John Dorsey aka Thanos some
love for trading up into the second
round because he saw damn
the best corner the best cover corner in
the draft the guy who's six two and ran
for three five is still available at
pick 46 and who everybody agreed was the
best man-to-man cover corner but his
knock was oh gosh he can't tackle
because we talked about tackling so much
with Deion Sanders and Darrelle Revis
and Darryl Greene such an important part
of their game they were so great at it I
mean that's why they're famous it's
because of their tackling
I don't ever understand that but John I
mean John Dorsey again to have the
vision to go whoa there's a there's a
corner that 6-2 has Richard Sherman type
measurables but it's faster than those
guys on the board I'm gonna make a move
and go do it and I just got to give him
a lot of credit and I thought that was a
great move by them you know a team that
didn't have a first-round pick and was
just really sitting there observing the
second round and made a move to get a
guy that I think has a chance to be very
special and and it's just funny when you
refer to John Dorsey as thinness I have
this vision of five weeks ago when we
were in Arizona and you called him with
a nose to his face and he looked at me
like is this good or bad like he's
completely he's even more clueless than
I am as to who
Thermo says alright alright here's
here's my next one no excuses for Curt
award goes to the Minnesota Vikings
because their first four picks all went
on the offensive side of the ball
and two of them two of them interior
offensive linemen who will be able to
execute the zone blocking scheme that
Gary Kubiak
is instituting as part of Kevin
Stefanski 'he's new offense and as you
chip away at well they got this problem
they got that problem the offensive line
isn't any good this guy's no good it's
it's and it's all gonna come back to
Kirk Cousins and as the team gets better
as the coaching gets better as the
offense gets better as the blocking gets
better the question is will the
quarterback play get better because they
can make all the excuses they want for
him based on last year this year it's
now abundantly clear that the Vikings
are only going to go as far as Kirk
Cousins can take them it's on him now
can he do it Chris
yeah I know that was a great pick for
them to get Bradbury
they certainly needed that something to
help Darren tear
I'm really I'm really shocked that you
went with something Minnesota related
really really surprised her there but I
just don't know for Kirk you're right
it's you know hey these the areas where
they need help they've addressed those
areas and now it's time for him to
flourish yes it is again you know with
his contract in this situation he's
gonna have to perform for tobacco sawed
off himself or get us off his back but
you're right there was a great draft
pick by them to get herb Smith in the
second round and then another lineman a
little later there in the fourth
certainly gonna help out the Minnesota
Vikings and Kirk Cousins does he's
running out of excuses he's gonna have
to perform big-time this year okay I'm
like what is that song with the beatles
help me alright you know help i need
some body is that right yeah it's just
helping yes help help me it's not the
fly well it's the Beatles I want to make
sure I just wanted to make sure and
that's my award to the Baltimore Ravens
because that's a little more Jackson was
saying going into this draft like help I
need somebody to throw do I need
somebody and he got two people okay two
to the first three picks I'm not a
singer so but I love it never stops you
I know it does not I love what Eric
takasi did for the Baltimore Ravens at
the top of this draft especially you
know to get two receivers Marquis Brown
a guy that can fly and just bombs away
and gonna scare the crap out of defenses
get a Miles borkus Boykin from Notre
Dame guy I've gotten a close look at the
last few years covering those games in
in in round three he's 6 for he's got an
unbelievable vertical 5050 balls balls
over the middle that's where Miles
Boykins gonna have great value for the
Baltimore Ravens so they got a little
bit of both that wide receiver and then
smashed in between those guys they got
arguably one of the most physical
physically dominating edge guys in the
draft and Jalen Ferguson at a Louisiana
Tech just screams Baltimore Ravens I
mean just big strong you know look scary
in his uniform and I feel like
Baltimore's got an eye for picking those
guys better than anybody else so got to
give decosta and the Baltimore Ravens
credit for what they did one observation
before we take a
yeah the only reason you're even aware
of the song help from the Beatles is
because it's currently on TV all the
time as part of a Google commercial you
had no idea that that song even exists
I'm a very well rounded classic rock guy
so don't do don't do that don't
stereotype me Mike Florio I'm very well
here's here's my challenge for you yes
find the help album it was the
soundtrack from a Beatles movie in the
mid sixties fine didn't listen to it
because he it is awesome and then there
are like seven or eight great songs on
help it's one of my favorite Beatles
albums that's your that's your insight
and thank you all wise one like Gloria
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports